we all know Donald Trump has said a lot
of hateful things I think Islam hates us
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime they're rapists and recently
protesters of Trump rallies have been
getting kicked out things got so rowdy
at his scheduled appearance at the
University of illinois-chicago that
Trump cancelled the event saying he
didn't want to quote see people get hurt
all this God is thinking that someone so
provocative as Donald Trump have the
right to speak on college campuses and
what rights do students have to stop him
let's start with the students the First
Amendment protects their right to
protest holding signs and peacefully
demonstrating a side of a trump
appearance is totally legal three
speeches it's a right we all have our
truth and our truth needs to be shared
but if your truth represents white
supremacy if your truth represents
colonialization if your troop represents
the death of my people then he will stop
you from speaking we will stop you from
showing up who will stop everything
having to do with you well you
definitely can stop him but preventing
someone from exercising their free
speech in a space that they've been
given to do so that's actually not
protected under the law and can get you
arrested peaceful protest fine
intentional disruption not so much and
then there's Trump he has the right to
speak on college campuses because duh
the First Amendment which protects more
than you might think but while Trump can
get away with saying some pretty hateful
things he can't say something that
intentionally insights or encourages
unlawful violence and he's so good at
towing that line like to punch him in
the face I'll tell you so if you see
somebody getting ready to throw a tomato
knock the crap out of would you
seriously I will pay for the legal fees
how is that not incitement to violence
well you could argue that it's not a
serious threat just a case of immature
braggadocio so those are the general
rules but seriously how does a guy like
Trump get invited to speak on a
university campus well there are two
ways first a university can invite or
uninvite for that matter whoever it
wants to speak on campus because that
speaker would be officially representing
the school it's
kind of like an endorsement the other
way is if a student group invites him
for this it's an all-or-nothing rule on
campus the university could say no
political candidates period well they
can't say it's okay to have a lorry
Clinton it's ok to have Bernie Sanders
it's okay to have other local say
political candidates but it's not but we
refuse to allow Trump because we don't
like his message that's a viewpoint
based restriction and that's not
something University can do so no matter
how offensive racist sexist Islamophobic
and generally awful Donald Trump's
speech is he does have the right to
express it and students also have the
right to protest it but is having the
equal right to speech mean having an
equal platform